so good afternoon and thank you all for
joining us on this truly momentous
occasion to introduce Yale's Nobel
laureate William Nordhaus
I'm Karen Pierre with the Yale office of
public affairs and communications and
you might you may fight all press
materials regarding this and other
announcements on our website at news and
also on our Yale social media channels
you may contact me and my colleagues
after the news conference is set up
one-on-one interviews with Professor
Nordhaus today you will hear from the
following speakers Dirk burgum on chair
of Department of Economics
Ted Snyder Dean of the Yale School of
Management
Kenneth Gillingham associate professor
of environmental and energy economist
Tamar Gendler Dean of the Faculty of
Arts and Sciences and finally Yale
president Peter Salovey who will
introduce Professor William Nordhaus
sterling professor of economics and
professor in the Yale School of Forestry
and environmental studies and now the
2018 winner of the Nobel Prize in
Economic Sciences for pioneering the
economics of climate change
please hold any questions until after
Professor Nordhaus has concluded his
remarks thank you and here's professor
bergamot
[Applause]
[Music]
good afternoon and and welcome everybody
it's wonderful to see so many of you
here to actually begin with the many
students a faculty of the Department of
the School of Management and a School of
Forestry president Provost and of course
to have bill here I should also say bill
should probably take comfort in the fact
that Bob Shiller's just sitting across
from him and so ready to give advice of
how to make it you know so the first few
difficult days of being a Nobel Prize
winner
so it's an immense pleasure to have
heard the news this morning that you
have been awarded a nobel prize in
economics together with paul roma from
nyu for integrating climate innovation
into economic growth builds work really
speaks to some of the most fundamental
and pressing questions of our time
involving the development of the global
environment and the economy bill has
really pioneered since the late sixties
early seventies of framework and it's
really monumental work in the sense that
it stands on its own to understand how
the economy and the climate of our
planet mutually dependent his central
concern since the early seventies is
basically how gross output and more
general you mafia may be constrained in
particular may be constrained by the use
of fossil fuels well received his
bachelor's his BA in 1963 from yale
university just four years laters the
PhD students should take note of that
just four years later see he finish the
PhD at MIT and came back to be then an
assistant professor at Yale and ever
since then he has been on the faculty of
the Department of Economics since 2001
he's the sterling professor of economics
the the highest academic distinction
that you can gather at Yale we have
starting this press conference a little
late
but they'll insisted that he wanted to
maintain his teaching schedule and so
this morning there was the class of
intermediate macroeconomics to teach
this year it actually has the highest
enrollment ever close to 200 students
and so that's the wisdom of the crowds
or the students may have known something
that we just learned today so this is
really really wonderful and and while
the price came out today really since
the very beginning of his dissertation
work under Bob Solow at MIT bill was
interested in the nature of economic
growth its relationship to technological
change and then since the early 1970s he
became concerned with the role that
natural resources can play for economic
growth there were two central papers in
1975 and then in 1977 the later one
actually was entitled very aptly
economic growth and climate the carbon
dioxide problem so that was very very
early on we'll hear of course from him
about this work directly but let me just
make a note that beyond the amazing
depths of his academic work bill has
always been a very dedicated public
servant from 1977 to 79 he was a member
of the President of the Council of
Economic Advisers and then 10 years
later roughly from 86 to 88 he was a
Provost of Yale University and just at
the beginning of this year he became the
chair of the Senate of the Faculty of
Arts and Science today he remains really
the leading economists on climate change
he currently directs a research program
the Yale climate change research program
an initiative that he just started the
beginning of the year with support from
the cold foundation and the Macmillan
Center for International Studies it aims
to bring together team of researchers at
Yale and elsewhere to develop new data
and new modeling tools to chart my
understanding of climate change and find
new concepts for potential cooperation
possibly next Paris Accords this program
emphasizes the interaction among the
countries it works and seeks to work
with universities are the univer
countries and then attempts to
understand the impact the climate has
has by using high resolution economic
data ok just this summer the Department
of Economics received generous funding
to create a new center for economic
policy aptly named after another year
Nobel Prize winner James Tobin so it's
called a Tobin Center of economic
policies and I'm looking forward for
Bill's work on the economics of the
environment and the global change to
become one of the major initiatives of
this new center so that is really very
much work to do
but today we're celebrating
[Applause]
good to see everyone this is a great day
for economics and a great day for Yale
I'm Ted Snyder and Dean of the School of
Management congratulations professor
Nordhaus I wanted to make two comments
that maybe go into a little detail on
what Dirk so aptly described as a
amazing career
Dirk mentioned professor Nord houses
service and I'd like to just focus on
one example of that he chaired the Yale
carbon task force a few years ago it's a
really interesting question what if the
market price for carbon related products
is below the price that we think it
ought to be given potential
externalities what Bill took on was well
how do institutions who are concerned
about that discrepancy adapt their
behaviors and correct for
overconsumption so this this particular
task force got into a lot of
nitty-gritty issues like how are costs
distributed through an organization what
happens you have buildings that are some
are leaky and some are tight what are
the tax effects of trying to correct
this how does the organization have
incentives to do to make adjustments
that make sense
fascinating inquiry but the point that I
find very relevant is that it wasn't
just a sideshow to do something for Yale
it reflected his connectivity to
problems and solutions and I think I
think you'll see that the matically
throughout his life's work the second
thing I wanted to mention is the way he
connects
with people about important issues and
one of my favorite examples is in a book
on gains for medical research and it
sort of became the the Nordhaus question
that got asked to all kinds of people
and I'm gonna adapt the question a
little bit but it's basically the
following if I look ahead to 2020 and I
have the option to have medical
technology associated with 2020 but with
that all other goods being back in the
1980s and I have that as an option or I
have as the other option I have all the
fancy all other goods devices and so on
and so forth the internet but I have
1980 health technology which would I
like and it as as soon as you ask that
question then it makes the issue that I
think was very real accessible to lots
of people
economists don't typically measure the
gains from life expectancy life
improvements in life quality etc but by
thinking about it that way you realize
those those gains are really important
to the gains that we typically do
measure so he has a great ability to ask
questions in ways that connect big
problems to everyday people and
policymakers so with that I'd like to
again congratulate professor Nordhaus
it's really been a great day and I look
forward to the rest of the comments
thank you
[Applause]
hi I'm Ken Gillingham I'm an associate
professor at the school of Forestry
environmental studies and I'd like to
heartily congratulate Bill North House
on this most well-deserved award those
had a profound influence on
environmental economics over many years
Bill's development of the dice model
which was mentioned already in the
remarks revolutionized climate change
policy in many ways he is you know there
are hundreds of papers out there that
are based on the dice model and yet
Bill's still developing it because he
wants to get it right and it's just
underscores Bill's meticulousness and
care the dice model work has even led
bill to coin a new term the social cost
of carbon when I worked for the White
House at one point when I was working
there we had many debates and
discussions about the social cost of
carbon and I've spoken to people around
the world in other countries in other
governments who also have many debates
about this social cost of carbon just
underscoring the profound influence
billa's had from the School of Forestry
environmental studies perspective were
also honored that bill has been involved
with us over many years he has a
secondary appointment he's jointly
advised PhD students and still is
advising PhD students with us he's
worked as a co-author with several of us
I've had the honor to work with Bill as
a co-author on several projects one of
the lucky ones and I've learned so much
from Bill I've been so impressed by his
creativity and I already used the word
meticulousness once but I'll use it
again meticulousness and joy with the
research process at really understanding
what's going on so with that I'll say
I'm thrilled by this award and I again
want to congratulate bill on this
incredible tribute
[Applause]
my name is Tamar Gendler I'm Dean of the
Faculty of Arts and Sciences and in that
role I have the honor of being the Dean
to bill Nord House bill is a person who
is shaped by and has shaped Yale bill
has spent 55 of his 77 years here at the
University and if he stays five more we
will have represented on the wall behind
me the number of years one for each
Nordhaus year at Yale in that time bill
has been outstanding in each of the
three dimensions that we asked our
faculty to exhibit in his research in
his service in his teaching you've
already heard from his chairman as of
his role as Provost of his service as
chair of the Senate of his leadership of
so many committees that the term the
Nord House report refers to an entire
stack of documents bill has also
excelled in his research epitomizing
Yale's commitment to asking fundamental
questions that transcend disciplinary
boundaries it's no accident that
speaking here today in Bill's honor is
the chair of the economics department
the Dean of the business school a
faculty member from the School of
Forestry a philosopher a psychologist
the president of the university bills
work draws on the disciplines that
constitute this university and its
characteristic of the border-crossing
nature of his work
that the war on climate change for which
he is being honored begins in
Mesopotamia and continues to the present
day bill is a person who draws on the
past to understand the present and to
shape the future and the shaping of the
future happens not only through his
research
it happens through his extraordinary
dedication to teaching in the last
twenty years bill has taught 74 courses
touching the lives of 3799 students and
the students whose lives he touches
right of this in the course evaluations
that they submit here are three
professor Nordhaus is obviously
extremely bright overall he tries to be
funny and occasionally succeeds
brilliant lecturer excellent knowledge
give this man a prize well we have bill
congratulations
[Applause]
good afternoon my name is Peter salivate
and the president of Yale University
I want to thank Karen and Dirk and Ted
and Ken and Tamar for their wonderful
comments I want to thank the members of
the media who are here with us this
afternoon to help us celebrate and to
share this celebration with the world
it's a wonderful day for Yale University
it's obviously a wonderful day for Bill
Nordhaus we're here to celebrate with
him our friend our colleague bill
Nordhaus the sterling professor of
economics professor in the School of
Forestry and environmental studies on
this announcement that he is the 2018
recipient of this various Oris Bank
Prize in Economic Sciences in memory of
Alfred Nobel you didn't know that is the
name of the Nobel Prize in Economics
today June today bill joins 60 other
nobel laureates who have brought
renowned to yale university as you've
heard from our Dean's and from faculty
colleagues he is a towering figure in
economics modeling and policy aspects of
climate change he's best known for his
pioneering work in integrated modeling
that links economic activity and global
climate change and he's developed
approaches that combine economic
analysis with earth systems models over
his over his distinguished career he's
worked extensively to estimate the
damages from climate change beyond his
scientific contributions he is committed
to clear an accurate scientific
communication on the major controversial
aspects of climate change and most
importantly as you've heard again and
again this afternoon he is a beloved
educator and mentor to scores of young
scholars as you heard he delayed this
press conference
so that he could teach his seminar he
just didn't want to cancel class but if
you don't cancel it on the day you win a
Nobel Prize you're never going to cancel
your class bill exempt exemplifies yells
focus on being a leading global research
a bill exemplifies yells focus on being
a low a leading global research
university at which our preeminent
faculty members teach conduct research
and advance their scholarship scholarly
work I would also add and our great
citizens of the university as a whole at
Yale we are galvanized equally by the
academic excellence of our faculty
members like Bill and their commitment
to educating the next generation of
leaders who will serve all sectors of
society from his groundbreaking
contributions addressing the economics
of climate change to his dedication the
teaching he is inspiring every one of us
to realize yells mission which is to
improve the world today and for future
generations through outstanding research
and scholarship education preservation
and practice Yale is proud beyond
measure that one of its distinguished
alumni and faculty members has been
awarded a Nobel Prize in Economics and I
am honored to introduce bill to you bill
[Applause]
thank you and for those remarks
those are just I don't know who that
person is but it's really nice to to
hear about I suppose what do you do when
a faculty member is speechless I don't
know that's that's not a good thing is
it well this is actually this is a
lovely day so if somebody asked me when
did you hear and actually that's a funny
story so being a Yale undergraduate and
a student of Keynes my ambition is to
spend the morning in bed
i cain't spent the morning in bad day he
was of course he was not just lying
there he was investing the funds for
King's College and writing his
correspondence and writing articles but
anyway I slept through it
and at seven o'clock I I got a call from
my daughter and said it's so nice and I
said what is that and that's how I heard
well it's it's true it's um you know
somebody said are you surprised well of
course you're surprised I mean there are
so many fabulous and brilliant
economists around the world and you have
to you have to be a megalomaniac to
think that you're the obvious one to be
chosen but I'll tell you I was really
surprised about was Paul Romer not not
for that not not for the reason you're
laughing
I figured it would be former colleague
here Martin Weitzman who is actually
extraordinary brilliant guy
person or Nick Stern who's a brilliant
economist and and probably the best
known economist who works on climate
change but Paul Romer had not crossed my
mind
the funny thing now the funny thing is
when I started just to go back a little
intellectual history when I started at
MIT as Dirk Mitch and I was working on
the we were taught economic growth by
the superstars by Bob Solow Paul
Samuelson Jim Tobin here challeng
Copeland's here but it looked to me as
if it was a it was closed I mean you
can't go and invent quantum mechanics a
second time it looked like everything
had been pretty much done but there were
issues about the side effects and were
also issues about technology so I
started out working on the economics of
technological change and how to
integrate that in growth models which is
what Paul Romer got a surprise for and I
decided after two or three years it was
too hard and so I just found something
simpler and I decided to do
environmental economics and climate
change which is actually much simpler
than technology an interesting thing was
but time the time I quit which was about
1967 and the time Paul started working
there were some innovations in
methodology particularly by Joe Stiglitz
another former colleague here that
allowed them to understand of how you
could integrate technology in a way with
imperfect competition so I was actually
very surprised and and very honored to
have Paul Romer to join with Paul Romer
who has done really pioneering work in
that part of economic growth theory so
then just to move ahead when when I gave
up on technological change as being too
hard then I began working with Jim Tobin
and we we did a project which we call
the green GDP project which was trying
to figure out how to how to integrate
non-market activity into our national
and I would say we we made a little
progress but not too much progress but
at that point this was in the early
1970s when the problems of global
environmental change were just I mean
not just environment which had already
come to the change but global
environmental change was coming to the
fore as well it was a great MIT report
about that time and the climatologist
particularly knew about climate change
and will becoming concerned in the late
60s in the early 70s it had not
penetrated economics I remember there
was a skit once an economics department
skit where the graduate students were
joking about I think it was co2 and the
multiplier which showed how much they
knew about both of them
Pachi Pachi a graduate student it's okay
there are now distinguished professors
somewhere but but gradually moved from a
joke to a serious concern among
economists I but the the motivating
force in this was the idea that there
are externalities there are these side
effects of economic growth which we are
poorly understood some of them might be
serious some but we don't know until we
investigate them and begin to integrate
them into our framework I was
particularly taken buttheads second
example of health health is another it's
an interesting example of something
that's not included in our measures of
GDP so let's say that our consumption
bundles stay the same but we live 10
years longer whether in this country or
in another country that actually doesn't
get reflected in our output measures
we're our per capita GDP any measure
that you know stays the same even though
we're healthier and we're living longer
and maybe we're happier as well
and I so that was another example of
trying to incorporate environmental or
other concerns into our economic
thinking and the example Ted used is
actually I thought was a good one
to try to persuade people that this was
important I would I would take a I would
in an audience like this I would say
okay I'm gonna do the experiment you can
actually you can go back to I used it a
slightly different time frame you can go
back to nineteen fifty living standards
and today's healthcare or today's living
standards in 1950s healthcare and then I
were to ask people okay how many would
like today's living standards in
nineteen fifty healthcare and invariably
the people under fifty would choose the
consumption bundle and the people over
fifty would choose the health bundle and
to which I concluded at the end of this
I report this and I'd say and I'd also
like to report if I were living with
nineteen fifty health care I wouldn't be
here to report on this so the the work
on climate change has been it's been a
it's been I said kind of spotty in the
sense that it's it's something that
start out and the problems we faced was
there was a there was a climate change
science but there's no climate change
economics there was no climate there was
really no climate change in agriculture
there are no damages there was no
international law respecting did with
respect to it there was very little of
the economic oh the the political
science of the game theory of treaties
so at the very beginning there was very
good climate science but there was these
all these other fields were there were
feels there but they didn't relate to
climate change and hardly related to
environment at all in the seven in the
70s and 80s so most of the work was was
going around and I remember quite
distinctly I would find a climate
and I say I know you have this huge
model and it's got like a million
equations but we can't put a million
equations in our economic modelling so
how are you gonna simplify it and this
was Steve Schneider if any of you know
his name and he would say well like
simplified to what like to a thousand
equations I said no like two equations
and so usually people would say oh
that's so funny you're gonna take my
discipline and put it into equations
it's like I'm gonna be out of business
so but but every once a while you would
find someone who would do that and so
the way you would do this is then put
the different different parts together
and in simple in simple ways the last I
think the last frontier of this if I
could use that cliche the last frontier
is the International side and Dirk
referred to this a little bit the
climate change problem is unlike most of
our problems like the the sulfur dioxide
problem or the congestion problem or the
water problem in being an international
problem and being a what's known as a
global public good and we don't have
mechanisms to deal with global public
goods so I think many people I include
people in this field in the field of
whether it's climatology or climate
science or economics you have a pretty
good handle on what how we can handle
this for a country for the United States
or for you as a group of countries but
the problem is how you're gonna bring
different countries together and this
this is a this is something that is I
think really plagued this area and I
won't go into the ideas here there are a
few that have been proposed but this is
that they're the last frontier of the
climate change you know I think we
understand the science I think we
understand the economics of abatement we
understand a little pretty much enough
the damages but we don't understand how
to bring countries together and that's
that's where we are
I think that the real frontier work is
going on today so let me just just
finish with one one final thought so I'm
here hello but I do think I do feel on
the background and the people who have
who have helped me who have taught me I
mentioned some of their names before
Paul Samson Bob Solow this University
Jim Tobin challeng Copeland's and others
I'll just mention those four and I
wouldn't be here I definitely wouldn't
be here at this table at this occasion
without them but I wouldn't be I
wouldn't even be there listening but for
this institution and I think one of the
things that is underappreciated is the
role of great institutions or of
institutions in general but great
institutions in providing the the
support not just financial support but
an emotional support and intellectual
support for doing the kind of work that
that this prize recognizes and the other
prizes that people have recognized if
you look at if you look at the names of
the people go back and look at them
they're not living they're not living in
some South Sea Island
virtually all of them are living in
great institutions and working in great
institutions are supported by great
institutions so I would like to myself
throw back on Yale whatever
congratulations you've given me because
I feel very strongly that it's a support
of Yale the people the institution the
people who've been here before the
people who maintain the standards of the
institution engage in the recruiting of
the students the recruiting the faculty
the support when they're here
you're waving fond farewell when they go
I think that's really what I take from
this is the most important the most
important message that these kinds of
prizes should give not just the
substance but also the importance of the
institutions that support them thank you
[Applause]
so if you have any questions please say
your name and your outlet that you're
from so the questions am I more or less
optimistic well I think I'm evil ly
optimistic as I was then I've my own
view is that there basically is no
alternative to market solution and the
reason is if you look around who are we
talking about that's gonna solve the
problem it's you and me there billions
of individuals millions of firms
thousands of governments hundreds of
nations and for them to take action
they're gonna have to have incentives
and the kind of incentives that we're
talking about they're not speeches we
can we can sermonize all day but is the
incentives of market prices and to raise
the prices of goods and services that
are carbon intensive and to lower the
ones that are less carbon-intensive
it's not the only thing to do I mean we
need to persuade people we need to we
need to educate sounds consenting just
condescending to say educate but I think
we do need to have people realize how
important a problem this is climate
change we need to introduce the right
incentives through and we also need to
develop the technologies all those go
together whether carbon tax is the only
way no there are other ways but I think
it's by far the most useful way the most
practical way the one if it's done right
through as we have at Yale in our carbon
charge system one that's rebates the
revenues back to consumers I think it's
actually the most durable one and one
that will be most effective susan hague
with The Associated Press do you think
this award and also the the report the
IPCC report will that give new momentum
to a car
tax uh so yes I don't know new momentum
and it will help I think one of the
problems is there's so much noise now
particularly in this country about about
climate change it's it's a hoax
perpetrated by the Chinese to help their
manufacturing being one hopes that is
particularly ridiculous given that
climate change science was invented in
the 19th century but I think it will
help it's always helpful to have bodies
that are bodies such as the Nobel
Committee or such as the IPCC remind us
about what the stakes are here I do
think that the carbon tax is not quite
caught on yet outside of the economics
community I think it's it's if you look
within the economics community the idea
of using a carbon taxes is a pretty
prominent and not just among liberal
Democrats but actually even more so I
think among Republican economists so
it's really across the across the
spectrum I think it hasn't penetrated as
much as it needs to into other
communities I think many scientists and
engineers never coming back to your
question a minute ago have the view that
this is something where you just need to
implore and exhort people to do things
but I think people are coming around to
you that you need more than that and you
need incentives I might add one thing
which is not obvious about it a carbon
tax with carbon price it's not just to
raise the price of goods and services
like coal-fired electricity but it also
gives incentives to firms to develop new
clean technologies for example if you're
GE maybe not the best example of
Brown company but you know it is a
company it is a company that does a lot
of energy technology and if you're GE
and C there's high carbon prices coming
and that's going to affect coal-fired
generation negatively and affect wind
power
positively then you would put your
research and develop money development
money into green technologies so this is
not just just to get to get people
consumers like you and me to pay
attention but in a way even more
importantly to get companies who do most
of the research and development on
energy technology to get their attention
well it's I think it's a case of two
steps forward and one step back this
administration won't last forever I
think there's a you know I think it's
really anomalous among in in the United
States this degree of hostility to
environmental policy and climate change
policy so all I can do is hope that will
that we'll get through this without too
much damage I it is outside the United
States it's pretty widespread acceptance
of the science and even the economics
behind climate change views and climate
change policy so I just I think we just
need to get through what is a difficult
period but I'm I'm extremely confident
that that will happen I don't think it's
it's not gonna stop climate change it's
it's there's a lot of momentum here it's
like a super tanker that it takes a long
time to slow it down but I think it's
something we can do
where you said that we don't understand
how to bring countries together all
those other countries I think it's very
difficult I think it's very difficult to
have an international agreement on this
this subject without the United States
participating and particularly the
United States is hostile its United
States it's a big country it's it's it's
an influential country so I but I think
we just have to pick up in a couple of
years or whenever it is we what we have
in place that we didn't have 10 years or
20 years is scientific understanding we
have measuring systems we have
monitoring systems we have we have
better understanding of all the systems
involved so we have in place the
intellectual infrastructure to do it but
we don't have the policy infrastructure
yet but you know what can I say we don't
we doing on that hopeful note thank you
[Applause]
the question
I can see why these passes
you